i stopped comparing myself and you know
it's
been said that comparison is the thief
of joy
that is what instagram is that is what
social media it is literally
and i talked to my wife about this and
i'm like she's like i don't follow
people like that you know i don't
i i follow you know she's like in the
science and she's
much smarter than i am and you know
she's like i don't follow that sort of
stuff i'm like there's no way
there's you don't just follow science
and
it's subconsciously we are seeing
a barrage of different people's
lives and i just think that there's
something innately in us
that we cannot help but compare on some
level it doesn't necessarily like
oh i want i want that car
it doesn't necessarily even happen like
that it happens in this very subtle way
that just gets at us and eventually
takes us out of the present
and takes away the joy and gratitude of
where we're at in our lives right now
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose
is to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize is
that we
are so much more alike than we are
different to quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and this show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
hello today on the show is you would
best know him as macklemore but
uh his name is ben and ben and i had
a really really deep cool conversation
about like the lessons of life about
um the creativity of music about
um community and how that applies to
not only our education as a human being
but
our relatability in our struggles
and how community is so important and
and he just has a really great
perspective
and all of his all of his struggles in
which he's so vulnerably shared
have been part of other people's healing
too
and i think that's a really really
beautiful role to play in the world and
not
not not everyone says yes to that but he
does and so we have a great conversation
about
all the aspects of that in the end how
we're so much more alike than we are
different
i noticed that you have like the most
appropriate
uh shirt on for me today with the
checkered flag on it
yes yes the checkered flag absolutely
intentional and thank you that's a
i take that as a compliment um and i'll
have you know that when i saw the name
of your golf clothing line i was like oh
bougie boys so
please don't judge me please don't judge
my ged
education level and the fact that my
mind was in a bougie place
but bogey boys make so much more sense
blindly slightly and it's funny because
that's where we met
was that a golf what is it at a golf
course this is true
yeah how have you been playing golf
during
all of the the last year i have been
playing a lot of golf
yes it is um completely taken over my
life
and i mean with covid the golf courses
got shut down for a while
and then when they opened back up it was
like well this is all that we can do
anyway
so i need to get outside the house i
need some sanity
i need an escape and golf is the perfect
tool
yeah um how have you been skewing
towards
less bogeys more birdies
i definitely bogeys are outweighing the
birdies
absolutely uh there was a i was starting
to get okay and then you know you try to
switch something with the swing and then
all of a sudden
you revert back to a higher handicap
than you had gotten down
to so i i'm i'm in and out of of
pars and buggies and a run of devils
you never know you know everybody goes
through that where you need to like work
on your swing i mean look at tiger and
you know i you know for saying that
crash seems so bad
um perhaps though he'll have more time
on his hands for
um for uh you know going out and playing
golf and giving little lessons
about how to have a new swing you know
it would it would definitely help me i
can tell you that
um i i i suck at golf like i mean
i i play a little bit i'm a member out i
live in scottsdale
and i'm a member at a course called
scottsdale national out here
um because bob parsons who started
godaddy who was my sponsor forever
um he was the one who bought it so i get
out like twice a year
which i think i'm the perfect member for
them i think there's about 10
people a day out there so if you're ever
looking for a course that has
um very low activity but two courses and
a
par three nine hole course uh and two
club houses
then scottsdale nationals for you it
sounds perfect
that sounds like my pace of golf my
level of activity
perfect yeah and there's like it's a fun
place to go because there's no rules
meaning like out here there's a place
called whisper rock have you ever played
at whisper rock
no no um it's a fancy place out here and
you know you can't and there's other
another one called estancia and
like you can't use your phone you can't
wear your ray
you know what at one of them like women
can't go most of the time
and um but at scottsdale national it's
like
headlights turn your music up and yeah
um you know talk on your phone wear your
hat have a good time so that's what
buggy boys is all about
oh well tell me how why do you have a
why do you have a clothing line i mean
design and
fashion in general has always been a
passion of mine i think that
um you know if i wasn't into
music i'd probably do something in the
design world we've always done
our own graphics our own merch our own
album covers music videos so that part
of it's always been entrenched in the
music that we
that we've done and um it was just kind
of a natural progression i got tired of
designing t-shirts with
my name on them then i'm like i just
can't wear this there's no way that i'm
going to pull this off ever
um nor want to so it was definitely a
you know a moment when i started playing
golf when i walked into
you know the pro shops and i'd be like i
just am not inspired by any of this
clothing like this is not
interesting to me and um i wanted to
create something that stood out that was
a little
bit different a little bit left fields
yet also paid homage to
uh era that was before my time where
people actually
had style on the golf course you know
people really
you have your arnold palmers and your
pain stewards and your lee trevinos and
chichi rodriguez guys that really um
looked fantastic i'm like that
is what where we need to take this game
we need to diversify this game it needs
to be more fun we need to be
make sure that whoever has wants a set
of clubs can get one
that we get the youth out there that we
really switch it up and kind of
shift this narrative of this white
stodgy elite exclusive club that golf
has been for so long
that's i mean that's true but yet i do
feel like there's like an
air of um kind of like i'm thinking
it's almost like a play on thrift shop
like there's like a play on like
old school like the plaids and like
almost like grandfather you're talking
about like the older players and like
they are grandfathers now so i did that
is that
is that it all like part of the sort of
i don't know not mindset but the uh the
design or the vibe
completely i mean i was dressing up in
old golf outfits before i ever even
thought of picking up a club i mean this
was this days back to me being in like
high school i mean this is where this is
where thrift shop came from was like me
going
into thrift shops getting out the
craziest plaid outfits that i possibly
could
and um and whatever else i could find
putting those clothes together making an
outfit that i couldn't go by
you know wherever department store
and and going out and having fun and i
think i just transferred that
into the actual game of golf when i
picked it up and i was like i just i
enjoy
i feel like i play better in a pair of
plaid pants
i just do i just play better both
there's something about it
when you said that it reminded me of a
story uh it's a funny little story but
it happened at a golf course
and um it was uh bill murray was there
and we're both from chicago and um so i
walked over to go say hi and he's like
oh hey you're from chicago
and i was like yeah and so he started
talking he goes what size clothes do you
wear and i was like
um this is weird and he goes and gets
close and he
and he takes this shirt and this like um
a cardigan
and puts it over it and like lays it out
like i think it was on a piano or
something like that
and he was like do you like this and i'm
like yeah sure
i'm sure you have it for someone in mind
because you're not a size small
and um and anyway so he's like do you
want i'm like
you know what i'm gonna play the best
golf
i've ever played when i wear that outfit
and this story reminds me it's like at a
golf course it's bill murray
and you know i said i'd play the best
golf i can
in that outfit i love it
and you know for the two times that you
play a year the one time that you wear
that
it's probably better than the other time
it it it
has worked every time so that's
basically that's basically the undertone
of your clothes is you're going to play
the best golf of your life
probably because you're going to be
having the most fun you've ever had
because you feel your best good this is
the new tagline i love this
best golf best looks like they
you know i've listened to some stuff
you've talked about and just
obviously your music over you know a
long long span of time
and um it's funny how you know you've
got
like the song thrift shop and it's about
kind of making fun of people and the
ridiculousness of you know
dollar t-shirt and um yet you love it
you love fashion
and now you have a clothing line and i
just think it's kind of a fascinating
little full circle
and psychology of the song and
the meaning and um
i just i just think it's very very
interesting so why
why why was that song written in the
first place i guess maybe is the place
to start
i mean i started writing thrift shop
years before it ended up coming out and
it was really a
critique uh not even a critique it was
more just kind of poking fun at the um
the overpriced nature of streetwear
culture at the time
which um was very centered around
the t-shirts and then also
you know talking about how i like to
dress um
it's funny because you know here i am
now
fast forward like you're saying to 2021
and
our t-shirts are 35 they're not 50.
and they're very heavy weight they're
very nice qualities it's like almost
like a sweatshirt
it's very thick it's very nice um
but i look back at the time and i'm like
man i should have i should have said
that the t-shirt was 500
i mean because now our t-shirt is like i
mean this is like 13 years ago and i
actually started writing the song it
didn't come out
years after that but um yeah now you
look at it in like a 50
t-shirt is like you know i'm talking
about a gucci t-shirt you can't get a
gucci t-shirt for under probably
400 bucks or something but it's just
more like
i think what i've always been fascinated
with is our
our obsession with designer
what we spend money on how we can
rationalize it what a logo makes us feel
like
and i complete you know i've never been
someone that's like pointing the finger
at other people
i'm completely caught up in it and i i
was back then too
um i think that there's a time and a
place and
obviously like spending money within
your means but like
um yeah i still
want that i still am like on looking for
the swoosh sweatshirt and looking for
you know a louis vuitton bag and like
all of these
things that um inherently don't function
any differently than something
that's you know a hundredth of the price
and i think that there's something
interesting with the psychology around
branding and marketing and what we spend
money on in terms of clothing
well it is programming i mean whether
it's the you know the program you're
watching or the things that you
are on your screen or your phone or tv
i mean it's programming i think it seems
to me like we're all becoming a little
bit more aware
of how programmed we are yes completely
but even like
i think that's exactly what it is and
even though
you know we're aware of it i still think
that with
social media we are so bombarded
whether it's consciously or
subconsciously with marketing
and looking at other people's lives
looking at what they're wearing looking
at the highlight
reel but as other people's existence um
and comparing ourselves feeling like i
just need that to make me happy
you know i just oh now i just need those
now it you know that would be the thing
that would really finish off my client
and it never stops
it doesn't stop it's this pursuit of
of the purchase that is like the
addiction and the high and i think that
we as a culture are
completely consumed by it as am i and
that's interesting
you know you look at other cultures and
it's just not quite the same way
you go to i mean places you know
definitely places like in india or uh
you know you go to anywhere over
even in some places in europe you're
just like people are not caught up
in this in this rat race to have to
consume
in the same way that we are in america i
just went to egypt
for a couple of weeks and i was walking
down the street in cairo at the end of
the trip
and you know everybody had i mean
they're kind of dressed similar
i mean there's definitely people dressed
in like regular jeans and whatever else
there's very much coverage so part of
our trip was about looking
looking like everyone else and
respecting their culture so you cover
your shoulders you know
cover your legs and you know there's
there's there's things that you do to
fit in and be respectful
and i kept thinking to myself when they
come over
to the states if they ever do what on
god's green earth do they think when
they
like say they walk down the street in
like beverly hills like rodeo drive
right and watch the scene
like what on earth or scottsdale where i
live like
what do you think they're thinking right
right why do we do that
why do you think we do that i mean you
said it we've been programmed we've been
programmed from a very young
age that this equates to happiness and
we are
you know constantly reminded
whether that's the billboard whether
that's the ad i mean we're talking about
last night
you know i'm i'm with my parents and my
wife and my kids
um you know a little bit north of
seattle right now
and um it is it's something that
the google the the whole what we're
googling and then what pops back up and
like i look at a pair of shoes on a
different website and then when i go to
nike it's like
the same shoes and the line like yo this
is crazy i mean the data that we're able
to collect or
they collect on us is is genius and
probably violating some sort of rights
but it's working well we all agreed to
it right when instagram came out with
that information that said
you know we're gonna this is what like a
month or two a couple of months ago and
they said we're gonna basically
we're you're giving us by continuing
with this you're giving us
permission to use your information and
see your information and i
had a moment of you know like a
conscious mic like i was thinking to
myself shoot i don't want them to have
it but i
want this platform you're not getting
i'm not giving up instagram
of course not right right so it's like
but then i thought to myself they're
already doing it
yeah long as i have this thing right
next to me
they know where i am they know what i'm
saying so what if they can see my actual
instagram it's like they already get it
all anyway
right data is apparently the biggest
business in the world now yep it's it's
the new gold it's the new oil
did you watch any of those documentaries
about it like the social dilemma and
no i need to watch the social dilemma
everyone keeps telling me that and then
i get
and then night time comes and i'm like
in front of my computer and i'm like
ah what should i watch i have no idea
no clue there's just something that
doesn't click with the social dilemma in
me being in front of netflix or wherever
whatever it's on does i have you felt
like i get this feeling like there's
uh you know which is really i think i
can relate to it that there's like a
departure have you felt a departure from
news from the programming or do you feel
like
it's still do you feel yourself i think
that
as much as when i it's
it's interesting when i have taken my
social media breaks
you know i wish that there was a way to
actually like
do studies on like real studies on
happiness um
scientific studies on happiness i think
that there is
something that happens in me where i
become more present i become more
spiritual i become more grounded
and you know what i stop comparing
myself
i stop comparing myself and you know
it's
been said that comparison is the thief
of joy
that is what instagram is that is what
social media it is literally
and i talked to my wife about this and
i'm like she's like i don't follow
people like that
you know i don't i follow you know she's
like in the science and
she's much smarter than i am and you
know she's like i don't follow that sort
of stuff i'm like there's no way
there's you don't just follow science
and
it's subconsciously we are seeing
a barrage of different people's
lives and i just think that there's
something innately in
us that we cannot help but compare on
some level
it doesn't necessarily like oh i want i
want
that car it doesn't necessarily even
happen like that it happens in this very
subtle way
that just gets at us and eventually
takes us out of the present
and takes away the joy and gratitude of
where we're at
in our lives right now you mentioned um
spirituality
and you know knowing about your story
and the things that you've gone through
um with addiction with success
um with humble beginnings with
paying record labels to put your song
out there which is brilliant
um do you feel uh
where does spirituality fit into all
that
um i think that spirituality for
me is crucial you know it's a huge part
of my recovery
it's uh it's what gets me out of self
right like when i wake up in the morning
um it's important to immediately remove
that self will
those desires that pop up in my head
like what do i want right now
what you know what do i need what am i
gonna do today
um and gets me in a place of of
a little bit like let me be guided by
the spirit let me
um let me help somebody else and i think
that when i'm in those seasons in my
life where i feel that gratitude and i'm
intentionally taking the time because
you know i got two kids a busy life
um you know from the minute that i wake
up it's like bam dad mode you're on
when i take that time when i find those
moments to really get
centered um to do some prayers and
meditation
i find that my life is better
it just is there's something about it
that becomes
easier more fulfilling and i have more
gratitude
when i'm just running and gunning on
like what's next what do i want like
okay bam bam bam
i get a little bit off i get a little
bit off i get
i lose some of the
some of that perspective that i think is
so important and it all ties back into
spirituality for me
so it's an incredibly integral part of
my life
did you grow up did you grow up with
religion at all or is it
i grew up in a i grew up going to
catholic church i come from an irish
catholic family
um but that wasn't that's st patrick's
day
yeah yeah yeah but that wasn't where i
found
my spirituality from um that's where i
found you know
that was a i was a kid and by the time
that i was
15 my parents were like you know you can
make the choice
whether you're going to go to church or
not and that's cool
i was like peace yeah it's not
christmas isn't that interesting i feel
like a lot of
um there's a lot of that there's a lot
of people that go to church growing up
and it's like
i don't i'm not i'm not i think it's i
think it has i'm
i subscribe to the uh religion
that i've at least seen on scene a
definition of omnism which is that you
don't believe in any one religion but
there's
truth in all of them um so of course
they're i think they're all they all
have roots of goodness but you know then
man
man gets a hold of them and you know
figures out how to make money um but
but i feel like it's so common that
people have to heal
from religion completely i mean i
definitely
when i first came into the rooms of
recovery i mean the word
god i was not comfortable with that word
at all
you know i had been um i had an
experience that i didn't resonate with
from the time that i was
you know i mean before i could remember
when i was baptized up until 15 that
um it wasn't a place that i found my
connection and that's not that's just my
experience that's not against anyone
else that
that finds their connection in a church
or a synagogue or mosque or anything
like that i think i agree with you
completely
the older that i get the more i became
removed from my actual upbringing with
the church the more that i could see the
truth in religion
and what i do think is amazing about
religion is that it forms a sense of
community
um people interaction humanity
feeling um you know being in the same
place with the same
intention of connecting with something
that is greater than ourselves that's
intangible
and that's super powerful that is really
powerful and it's
incredibly and powerful in in this day
and age
where we are we are so much on our
phones we are so
now we're on zoom you know we're not in
person
we're we're working from home we're not
around other people and i think that
that is a
a very you know impaired part of the
human experience to be able to
get in a room with people and whether
that's in work whether that's in in
prayer or worship
and and have like-minded intention
i think we're meant to be in community
right i mean that's we're not meant to
do this by ourself
and you know you've talked about how
important that community was
with recovery and realizing you're not
alone and
you know i've done this in my own life
where i realized that when i
am vulnerable enough to share the things
that are going on with me i give
people even if it's on a simple level of
like
i don't know not looking put together or
you know being making mistakes or what
it could be really simple it doesn't
have to be super big and complicated
but i then give that person permission
to
show the same otherwise if i'm perfect
if i'm put together if i make no
mistakes that person does not feel any
comfort to not look perfect to not make
mistakes and that's not
living no that's that's exactly
you know that gives it gives me some
goosebumps because that's exactly
it and that is and that is what for me
recovery is all about that's why it
works
it's because we come in there and we
share our struggles our experience and
our hope
and when you do that open openly and
honestly
with willingness to be open to
whatever's in the room and you just
share who you really are and where
you're at
that's where there's power that's where
that vulnerability is contagious and
that's what
that's where my best music has come from
that's when i've been the most tapped
into my spirituality
i'm not trying to project an image i'm
not trying to be performative i am
literally just sharing
where i'm at in the moment in all its
flaws and imperfections
um there is beauty and yet we try to we
try to
to hide that right because we feel like
we have to keep up
with everyone else and you know we need
to put the filter over our picture and
you know everything needs to look
pristine and you in in
what we really are craving is
that imperfection that is what makes us
feel human
and we feel seen when other people are
going through the same thing and we
become closer as a community
that's that magic yeah was there
an aha moment that that that came to you
or a story from
um being in these groups and commun and
talking to each other that like
broke you down and broke you open
uh i have a horrible memory for
pinpointing
certain you know experiences but i think
over time
um you know what it was you know you
know i've relapsed multiple times but
every time that i would come back once i
found my core group of people that
you know my real community once i found
that in seattle
um i would relapse and there's so much
guilt and shame over um
over relapsing you know you're like oh
my god i'm never gonna get this
i lost i had two years and now i'm back
at day one
and people are gonna judge me and um
every time that i that i would that i
would do this and i would come back
and you know there'd be times where i
wouldn't tell anybody for
for weeks on end and you know finally i
learned like dude
when you do finally tell people you are
greeted with love
with with the hub with um complete
understanding because
most of us have gone through something
like this um
there is no judgment and at the end of
the day
i'm trying to save my own life like we
have a very short time on this earth
and how much of that time is spent
trying to cater
to um you know what other people think
of us
like just share your truth like
my name is ben i'm an addict and like i
have i have one day today i'm just
coming back
and every time that that happened um it
was
nothing but love and i realized that
these people aren't here to judge you
they aren't here to like point the
finger if they are that's their own
journey
and their work to get through but i'm
trying to save my life
yeah yeah would you what would you
say your greatest lesson has been in
the experience of addiction and
relapsing and coming back
and having your people and finding your
people
i mean i think it's kind of all of this
and this is like everything that we're
talking about i think that um
for me so much of the disease the
disease is rooted in
in self-centered thinking and um to be
able to get outside of self
to truly give to others to be of service
to tap into a spirituality that i knew
nothing about beforehand
all of these things in combination of
the community
um are what keep me coming back you know
and i realize that i have
the disease of addiction i am not going
to ever be cured from this thing it
doesn't end
and to be completely honest with you
danica like i don't want it to
end this is the way that i've been able
to find a deeper truth and a deeper
meaning in my life
and i wouldn't trade it for anything
it's caused a lot of pain absolutely but
that pain has turned to growth
if i do something every single day
around the disease
what have you what it what uh then
what's the biggest gain i mean that's a
beautiful way to look at it i
i you're saying yes to the lessons which
and the growth of it which is something
that most people don't do and it's scary
to go into that it's scary to go into
the vulnerability it's scary to
change things and sure you've had to
change friends and all kinds of stuff
um but to to be able to see the
the the the golden lining of it all
and be able to recognize that there's
growth in it um
what has been the i mean there's things
that you've lost but what's the gain
what's been your favorite gain i mean to
me the gain is that i get to live an
honest
life today you know i wake up in the
morning and
i'm not you know riddled with with
with fear with guilt with shame from the
night before
um i don't have the compulsion to use
i don't i'm not like oh my god how am i
gonna you know how am i gonna get high
today how am i gonna pull this off or
whatever it is
um i get to wake up with my kids i'm i'm
there
i'm in their lives i'm a good dad
i'm an honest partner all of those
little things
that um i don't take those for granted
anymore because i realized that the
minute that
i let the disease of addiction um back
into my life
um with active using all of those things
go away
all of those things go away and i always
wanted to
um i wanted to think when i when i had
my first daughter that
um she was gonna keep me clean right
like she was gonna be
like okay now i can't get high and
that's not the way that the disease
works unfortunately um i can't do it for
her
or because of her i have to do it for
myself
and she can be ins she's a huge
inspiration
but i need to do this for me and she
can't keep me clean my wife can't keep
me clean no one
could keep me clean um except me and my
power
and a in a connection to a power that's
greater than myself
that's it it sounds to me like when you
you were talking about like taking the
time to um
for yourself whether it's through any
kind of spiritual practice that you have
it's like
it's like when you say yes to that that
part of you
you say yes to the other other people in
that same way
and and when you don't then you don't
say yes to them either it's like a
parallel
you know as soon as if you wake up and
every day you start the day
saying sort of honoring yourself you
start honoring everything else in the
day
right completely absolutely um
i always feel like there's you you
talked about you know like
not wanting it to be over and i think
about the
you know the artist's side of you and
um it's an interesting because you said
too that
great music and inspiration comes from
that and creativity
is there any feeling that you're going
to lose that
if you don't have this relationship with
this struggle
no um well i guess that's a great
question
because usually people i i said no
because i thought you were going to say
with the relationship with this drug
which usually people think like oh but
you get
clean and then you can't like make music
and it's like no it's never been the
case
um but the struggle that's a great
question
um i think that the struggle's always
going to be there
like there's in in
addiction is not just for me with with
drugs
i'm an addict for anything that changes
the way that i feel so like
yeah that that struggle is always going
to be there to a certain extent i think
that there
are infinite ways to write music and
um if i want to tap into that struggle
i can i can do so of course if
everything in life
is just going great and you're like now
i need to like write a struggle so i'm
like
no now is not the time to write the
struggle song you know like
you know it's time to write the
celebration song you know like wherever
you're at is what i like
where i like to make music from um
but inherently life is going to present
its its struggles
and they change and they morph and they
turn into other things
it's always something and um
you know i'm sitting there last night
with my parents and and
you know they're in their 70s now
and thinking about that next chapter of
life and
you know
they're that's scary it's scary to think
about
my parents passing on and you know what
that's going to be like and when one of
them you know they've been happily
married forever and
when one of them goes and there's always
things that are coming up in life that
are going to present
its own challenges and cause us to
to learn and to grow and to go through
pain that we don't want to go through
how do we do that
um community right right absolutely
there's an interesting sort of
view as to
growing up today and
how in the old days like a long time ago
it used to be
in community and it used to be you know
with elders around you and you had
grandparents and you had
you had all kinds like the community of
the family
and the and and those intertwined in it
was really wide and deep and so when you
think to yourself
that all you really have is your parents
it's like
or maybe some people don't even have
their parents it's like
who's teaching you the lessons who's
giving you the wisdom
and i feel like it's in the community
that you gain the wisdom and we've so
lost that
we've absolutely absolutely
yeah we are you know even
i had to talk to him i had to talk to my
parents a couple years ago and be like
yo
i want you guys around i i want to
see you more i don't want and we loose
enough you know they're they're a couple
hours away from me and
we live close enough that um it's kind
of a weird distance because i remember
when my parents my grandparents
come into town like they would come from
boston
and um they'd stay with us for a week
and we'd go stay with them for two weeks
in the summertime
there was three condensed weeks of
of seeing them which is so much more
valuable to me
than like you know every you know
once a month they pop in for a couple
hours like that's not
that doesn't feel the same that feels
like a quick catch-up there's something
about what you're talking about really
soaking up
game being part of um
being part of family and and and having
those conversations in in the
ideal in the idle time like we're not
hosting you know it could feel like that
in times but when they come over it's
like you know
up here we're in our cabin and it's like
it feels nice to just like
relax you know we don't we don't have
anywhere to go we don't have some like
crazy agenda we're not rushing out of
the house it's like
let's be with one another um
yeah i prefer it yeah i don't know how
else you get
how else you get that uh you know width
of wisdom
unless you're around people that have
been around for a while
and i just don't think that's that's so
that's not as normal and
you know especially with everything
going on in the world and how we can't
freaking see anybody and they've
especially put people that are older in
such
fear like i mean of all people like that
i feel like they've been the ones put in
the most fear that oh it's
you know the virus is coming for the
older ones the most and then it's just
like
you know it's such an isolating time and
i i just
i don't know do you have any like i
don't get it
completely it doesn't all make sense and
i feel like we can almost agree on that
i don't
i'm kind of putting words in your mouth
there but do you feel the same
that we in terms of
the virus coming for the older people
and people being scared i mean
yeah the whole damn thing like the whole
thing like i mean california still isn't
able to eat indoors
i think at this point it's been a year
the two weeks has been a year
and like you know just the the protocols
and the
the you know there's so much like you
know cancer
culture and canceling opinions and
you know i have people who say things on
social media and their
they get shut down and you know shoot i
don't know how this makes you feel about
writing music but do you feel like
you're being canceled in some way and
for sure your shows have been canceled
which is a huge bummer because in my
opinion
music is super healing and just the
energy and the frequency of the music
itself being
live is so much more it penetrates so
much deeper
than even on the radio and that being
it's like
that it's being in that community of
people who
are there for the same reason you're all
happy you're all having a good time it's
like a mini church session right where
you just
all like-minded people enjoying the
music and in a positive vibrational
state
with the energy of the music in real raw
form
and like that's been completely shut
down so
um it's such a that's kind of what i
mean is like it just doesn't all make
sense it just feels like
we're being broken down in some way yeah
i think that that's very accurate um
and i mean i think that we're gonna look
back on what
2020 was and obviously we're not through
this thing and we're
you know a quarter of the way through
2021 but um
this has been a huge shift
in terms of our consciousness is
humanity
in terms of everything that happened in
2021 the black lives matter movement the
political race the iv you know the
pandemic everything was just kind of
this
melting pot of um
of change and it was uncomfortable
and we continued to feel that um
you know you brought up canceled culture
and
one thing that in relation to what you
were talking about
earlier that i think is so dangerous
with cancer culture is it doesn't allow
people to grow
we are we become so afraid of making a
mistake that we don't
say anything and that's not where that's
not where we need to be right now you
know
as all of us and i think that we need to
be having the uncomfortable
conversations about race we need to be
having the um you know those
conversations with our family members
with you know
we need to use our platforms we need to
be bringing issues to the forefront but
if we're so scared that we're going to
get
cancelled that we're going to say the
wrong thing that
something's not going to be perfectly
worded or politically correct
we need to feel i think as people um
that we can make mistakes and
not be persecuted for them and you know
not that we shouldn't be held
accountable
but that these mistakes end up
in potentially getting cancelled that's
just dangerous
it's it's really dangerous and i think
that that whole kind of
movement around this person's done like
this like you know 23 year old said this
thing they're done forever
like that is so um
it's dangerous and i'm worried that
you know this next generation and in all
of our generations that we're living
through
right now are are going to be so
paralyzed that we just don't say
anything because we don't want to be we
don't want to be called out
and the fear of getting called out is
greater than the fear
than the action of speaking truth
well said
people need to think about that you
think about why you do and don't say
something
and what's in line with your truth and i
feel like if there's one thing that you
have
done so well
with your music through your music
with yourself but through your music is
be honest
and you talk about
things that are happening in culture
that people aren't talking about you
talk about things that are happening
with yourself that people aren't talking
about
um with themselves personally and
um so it makes me kind of want to ask
the question
what do you want to say how do you want
to
what do you want to tell people what do
you want to say to them what do you want
to wake them up to
how do you want to like how can we
elevate our consciousness
to the point where we can all start to
get along like look i have friends who
are
we don't all believe in the same thing
at all i have and and that's and that's
what i realize is that we all get along
great as people i'm like wow there's all
these like surface level beliefs that
are different
but we have an amazing time together and
have so much fun and we're so much more
alike than we are
different and so how how i don't know
what do you
how you you're a change maker through
your through your platform
what do you want to say oh adam that's a
huge
question i i do think that what you're
talking about is interesting though in
terms of your friendship groups i think
that with
you know the how intense it got with
trumpet really
created a line in the sand in terms of
um yeah who you could even be friends
with
like the family members that you would
talk to or not talk to like it got
that divisive and um
that's also you know what when it's just
black or white
when it's just you know you're on this
side or that side those are
really um that's a scary place for
for society to be in you know there's no
nuance and
it is something that makes our what what
makes our country
you know so interesting is that we have
people from all
different walks of life we are a
extremely diverse country as a whole
and yet if we're either have to pick
right or left
then we're not getting into the core
belief system of what
really makes this integral experience of
humanity
like like the ability
to connect her to see differences like i
can i completely have the same
experience and i think that
with with friendship groups of not
feeling the same not being aligned
i don't grow if i'm just around
like-minded people i don't
i don't i don't actually um i'm not
i'm not pressed to actually think about
a different way of
of of life when i've
opened up my circle and you know
honestly a big part of this did come
through recovery
um when i open up my circle and i'm like
damn i didn't think that i would have
anything in common with you i judged you
i looked the way that you were dressed
i looked at the car that you pulled up
and i looked at the accident that you
had
i looked at you know how you sat i
looked at the coffee
all these things that are subconsciously
happening that we are just
stacking up to judge somebody who they
are um
all of that math was completely wrong
it was completely wrong and actually who
you truly are at your core
i love i love and
looking for the similarities rather than
the differences
i think that it's so easy to look at to
look at the differences and be like no
we don't add up
that doesn't make sense that's not what
i believe in um
and it's more complex than that and the
other thing the internet makes
makes all of this worse right the
internet is
a place where people you know
it's like when you have a conversation
with someone there's people that i
that i have great conversations with but
when they text me i'm like this is like
a completely different person
like this level of communication is is
is
horrible like you know and then i i'm
like damn like they really
this is this is so bizarre and then i
talk to them in person and i'm reminded
oh yeah when you type something out
and press upload or send or comment or
whatnot
there is no tone to that there's no
personality to that
and people speak in absolutes and they
and they have a next level of
bold expertise that might not exist in
real life when you're one-on-one
so i think that these are all more
reasons why community is important in
having a different set of community
that's
bigger than just the insular one where
we can actually learn from one another
hmm yeah i've heard that from various
different people like i remember
interviewing gretchen carlson
and she was describing the way that she
learns about her news even she's like i
watch all of them
she's like i just i i watch all the news
sources so that i get
a wide so i can get an assessment of all
of them and make my own decision
and you know i think that should be said
about about
our lives too like you know the thing is
is we we're so
solid in our beliefs right we're just
like so solid
and then we tend to through tv through
social media
through the computer through the things
that we say and through the
people that we spend our time with we
just continue to
perpetuate the same story until we get
someone else in that we start to end up
realizing that we're all part of the
same whole
and that the common denominator is like
we all struggle which is why
vulnerability is so critical because
we're all struggling with something
like you've seen that said many times
like you know someone walking down the
street like
you know they might look really happy
but they're out they're struggling too
or if they're
if they do something that irritates you
it's like you don't know what kind of
day they had
um and that we all want to be happy like
we all struggle
and we all want to be happy
and the only way we can know that is if
we spend time with other people
do you are you writing music or i mean
what are you always writing music
no definitely not always writing music i
am i've taken a little bit of a break i
think that
i was in a zone as coveted hit
and i've been kind of in and out
bogey boys is obviously it's been a huge
maybe not obviously it's been a huge
undertaking um for me
just in terms of time um being home
with with two little girls and you know
zoom school and and that's right
you have to be known a teacher yeah i
mean
luckily they're finally both back um but
zoom school was really tough they um
yeah it just is another you know we lost
our nanny for
four months or something like that when
code first hit
and it's it just life got real i'm on
i'm not used to being home for
this amount of time like i'm used to
constantly
leaving and coming back and traveling
and all of a sudden it's just like
nope you are a dad and you're not
leaving your house
and um so yeah it was a little bit
challenging for me to really draw
inspiration to go from straight dad mode
to like you know i'm doing the dishes
and then i go downstairs in the basement
and
now i'm a rapper and you know i made
music
it just felt a little bit strange um
but yeah the the songs fortunately have
have not dried up you know i'm excited
about the music that i've
that i've made in the last couple years
i'm excited to put it out when it will
come out i have no idea because of the
uncertainty of
the touring business i i really don't
want to put out an album
without being able to go get in front of
the people and perform it
so we'll see i think that by this time
next year uh touring in some capacity
should be
um should be opened up that is that is
the hope that is the
insider tip that i've been given with
the information that no one really knows
well you're a gemini you know i i say
i took a couple levels of astrology so
i'm like oh he
literally wrote you wrote an album
gemini and i was like so
um it made me think that you um
well basically knowing that about you
which i didn't need to say anything but
you
since you called called that gemini um
you're a communicator i mean like like
gemini's are
error sign like you are a communicator
so has it been
more painful to not travel or
like what's been the most i'm kind of
curious what do you want to keep and
what do you
like what do you want to keep from this
whole experience that you're like man
this is the one thing that
this is something that i would say like
never go back from this
and then what's something that you can't
wait to get back
the thing that i have
benefited from the most of this most of
this experience
um is that i got to be
with my kids and i got to be with my
two-year-old her entire two years you
know from two to three she had her
birthday
three days ago and i got to be with her
damn near
every day of that and um
we're super close and i wouldn't have
been as close to my daughter
had i been you know home
200 days out of the year versus 365 you
know
it just wouldn't have been the same um
so you're gonna are you gonna stay home
more is that what that implies that you
don't want that to change
i i think that there is something i
think that life is is very precious
and um it's always a balance
i will definitely be touring when
touring opens back
up and that's the thing that i'm the
most excited about um
but it what it really did for me was we
all had to go into a mode of acceptance
right no one wanted this no one was like
yes
finally like um a pandemic
no no one wanted this it interrupted it
disrupted
um our lives in a
drastic dramatic form um
but what it did for me was it reminded
me that acceptance is key
and that um regardless of what is
happening
that there is um gratitude to be found
that there is a connection to be found
and that
um life happens for a reason and
sometimes we never
understand what that reason really is uh
you know
it's so cliche but i i subscribe to that
and i don't
i might not ever find out why i might
not ever
um understand why this door closed and
this one opened but i do believe that
they're closing
all the times at all times and that
eventually um if i can just accept it
and fall into it that there is beauty
from those moments and that's what the
pandemic has reminded me of is that
um i don't control life but i control
how i react to it
it's all i got control over and so then
you can't wait to get back touring then
so
it's funny because those are is that
what she is that is that what you can't
wait that's the that's the duality
exactly i love my kids but i can't wait
to get back on the road
but it's of course being with your kids
so much and being home essentially it's
not like the kid but it's like
the home home that makes you crave the
going
and it's going that makes you crave the
home and you end up they're part of the
same hole
they're not separate yes
yes yes completely i mean yeah when i'm
on the road i'm like oh my god i just
want to get home and when i'm at home
i'm like oh my god i need to get out of
here it's
it's non-stop it's about accepting where
you're at
being finding happiness happiness in
that moment and um
and this has been covert has been a
ultimate teacher it's this is there's
lessons there's
infinite lessons in these moments um
and hopefully and i think that for a
while
for me when coveted first said it was
like my disease was like oh perfect
you know oh now you have an excuse what
you you have an excuse to get high now
and just be at home
and you know i you know it my disease
started talking real loud
when kobe first hit and um
i want i want to leave
you know whenever this pandemic is over
if it's over who knows what what the
world is going to look like but
i'd like to think that i'm coming out of
it
with some new tools you know i think
i would like to come out of it i want to
say like a better person but like
you know with some new tools you know we
we went through something
and i'm coming out of it a little bit
better than how i went into it
if you used it right i think that's the
i think that's what happens
i think that we all have an opportunity
in life when things are difficult
we can either let it catapult us into a
new level of acceptance understanding
peace presence and
or we can allow it to
get into our psyche and we can spin
on a negative thought and it just spins
us down
down down down and we all have that
choice
and so i think that you've used it
properly and so you should be
proud of yourself for that thank you
thank you
yeah well congrats on the new clothing
line i can't wait to uh
get some bogey wait are you gonna do
bogey girls
we gotta figure that out come on now
figure it out i know
yeah i mean the closer unisex obviously
the name is not
but um we need to figure that out there
are
a lot of clothes though that i will say
swing both ways well i the more
time goes on and the more guys like
harry styles wear
you know boas and girls clothes um
but um whatever if he makes him happy uh
but i hear from people in passing like i
was just you know there's a guy on trip
to egypt and he was talking he's
you know stylish and cool and he's like
i buy women's clothes he's like
absolutely
like these shirts that are like this
he's like they don't make them for guys
and they don't make this cut
so i think that the idea that things can
be unisex is
uh really like it's not it shouldn't be
shocking it shouldn't be scary
it should just be you fitting into the
clothes that sort of suit your style
and um you know just because it says
boys doesn't mean that it can't be for
girls so
i like that very true very true you're
making changes with your clothes now too
so i mean i mean what you're saying
though is so true i
i've shopped women's clothes forever
like
you know you can't find as much fringe
in the men's section as you can the
women's section
so i have i have infinitely shocked uh
you know in the women's department it's
been absolutely part of my story i love
what harry styles is doing i think that
it's great
i'm i'm in you know gucci the other day
and i'm looking at the person i'm like i
pull off the purse like this is a great
and and you know i i posted it on
instagram and
you know quickly realized like i mean it
was like
60 60 40 type where like you could do it
versus you couldn't but i i
i went back the next day i was like wow
that really is like a first post
that's not like that can't even be like
considered like a man bag
or like a a a man's satchel that is just
a straight up purse that i would
normally be holding for my wife
but you you know you never know you
never know
there's no boundaries here well maybe
maybe the final question is do you
actually shop at thrift stores ever
like i have oh oh constantly
constantly i am of course
with coke there has been limited
thrift shopping but uh your boy
fired up the ebay account i got the etsy
i'm on offer up i got all the all the
social media
all the all the internet's uh you know
thrift shops it's all attainable now
so constantly i just have boxes coming
into my mailbox
um i'm like oh yeah i bought that two
weeks ago it's not not the best shipping
time but okay
yes i forgot that i ordered this sweater
um so that's
that's been a new somewhat healthy
addiction of mine
is is the vintage shopping online i'll
always
i'll always buy used clothes i love it
it
you know they're they're one of a kind a
lot of the time you can't you can't go
out
and buy that you can't you can't buy
that history and that lineage that those
clothes provide so
you have somewhere to wear them which is
the problem i end up like i mean
i think to myself like there's no need
to go shopping like i mean i'm gonna
promise you i have yoga pants on
underneath this
i need like shirts for a show that's
about it like i don't you know we don't
go as many places but
um but that will change and you know
what there's something to be said
about like the vibe it gives you just to
have it even if you're like
like i'm just walking around your house
one day or
you know doing a zoom interview yeah
shirts shirts on shirts shirts on shirts
all right well thank you so much and
congrats and thanks for your honesty and
giving us all permission
to do the same you know some people come
into this life with
more to carry and um a big job and i
think that you
you you have that and you're doing it
like you're doing that
and uh so thank you thank you danicas
very nice usa
and um really appreciate you having me
it's been a good conversation
i invite you to scottsdale national to
come play with me hey we're playing
boys clothes two times a year to three
times a year we're doing it
all right thank you so much thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more
please click on the subscribe button